(audience clapping)
- It is super cool
when you find something
that speaks to you online,
and I love to share my favorites.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
A New York city fashion blogger
is helping shine a light
on people of color,
making a splash in the style world.
Claire Sulmers is the founder
of Fashion Bomb Daily.
A site that chronicles
everything from fashion news
to trends, to wardrobe advice.
And with more than two point
four million viewers a month,
the site is a great resource
for what's happening in the
world of multicultural fashion.
We've got Claire on the line just back
from Paris Fashion Week.
(audience clapping)
Great to meet you.
(audience applauding)
Oh, you look fabulous.
- Hi.
(audience clapping)
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God you look stunning.
You look so beautiful.
It's great to meet you.
So, why was it important for
you to create a site like this?
- Yeah.
Well, growing up,
I was a fashion fanatic
and also a magazine addict.
But when I looked through magazines,
I very rarely saw women
who looked like me.
Kirby women.
Women of color.
And so I decided to
create Fashion Bomb Daily
to be the change that I
wanted to see in the world.
And to create a simple
platform of one stop shop
that showed women and men who reflected
just dope style.
Everyday people no matter their age,
no matter their culture or background
and no matter their size.
- I love it.
(audience applauding)
Oh, that's so cute.
Well, you're not just
writing about fashion,
you also created a marketplace
to help small fashion designers
and businesses, right?
- I did. Yes.
In 2018, we created
Fashion Bomb Daily shop.
It's a platform for emerging
multicultural designers.
- And fashionism. Very
capital heavy business.
If you're a beginning designer,
a lot of times you need connections
or you need a lot of money.
And so I decided to create our...
To use our wonderful platform
to empower designers who
might not be able to connect
to influencers or
celebrities, for example.
And I'm actually wearing a
design from our shop today.
Its by a designer named Oyawen.
She's a Nigerian American
designer out of Atlanta
and her designs have been
worn by Khloe Kardashian,
Doja Cat and lots of
Housewives like Lilney White,
Porsha Williams and Marlo Hampton.
(audience applauding)
- That's amazing.
It's awesome.
You look so cool.
Thank you so much Claire
for everything you're doing
for so many people.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(notification dimes)
(audience clapping)
That's not all.
So, usually this is the part in the show
when we'd give our guest money,
courtesy of Pilot pen makers of friction
that go to race bull pin
at the Kelly Clarkson show.
Instead, we're gonna give the
thousand dollars to a lucky
studio audience member
who can use it at Fashion Bomb Daily shop.
So let's see who it's gonna be.
Here we go.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat drum music)
Look under...
Look under your chairs cause
someone's got the check.
(audience applauding)
It's already there.
Is it under your chair?
(upbeat drum music)
- Yay!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
(audience clapping)
(laughing)
- Hi!
(audience cheering)
- What's your name?
- My name is Daisy
- Dai... Oh, what a beautiful name.
- Thank you.
- So where are you from Daisy?
- I actually just moved to
California six months ago from
the east coast, Boston.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
Well enjoy.
Congratulations on the move.
You can now buy some really cool clothes.
- Yeah.
There you go!
(laughing)
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you for coming today Daisy.